a los exuberantes escenarios de tu mar
volen están de vuelta en bélgica este
año los apasionados de la música
electrónica tienen tres días más para
ver a sus artistas favoritos esta
prórroga pretende compensar las pérdidas
por unos 28 millones de dólares causadas
por las cancelaciones de las ediciones
de 2020 y 2021
fue bastante difícil empezar de nuevo
porque llevábamos mucho tiempo sin un
festival y echamos de menos a los
compañeros de trabajo pero seguimos
llenos de energía positiva y estamos muy
contentos de estar aquí de nuevo una
alegría compartida por los festivaleros
que disfrutan del espacio como antes de
la pandemia los tapabocas son casi
inexistentes tal como el distanciamiento
social
supongo que no tenemos que tener miedo
ese es el siguiente paso correcto por
algo hemos pasado por la vacunación por
eso estamos aquí para disfrutar para
maximizar nuestra experiencia que a
partir de aquí el tiempo lo dirá pero
hoy vamos a disfrutar y volver a nuestra
vida normal
se esperan 600 mil personas de más de
200 países algunos de ellos vienen de
muy lejos
soy de perth en australia la costa oeste
de australia estuvimos confinados unos
dos años y medio fuimos de los primeros
en salir así que vinimos hasta aquí para
este festival este festival en
particular el mejor festival del mundo
sin duda increíble
durante estos tres fines de semana de
julio más de 7 100 dos artistas se
turnarán en 14 escenarios para poner a
bailar a los espectadores del mayor
festival de música electrónica de europa